Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said
this morning that the president is very
committed to the Middle East peace
process but Tillerson would not discuss
mr. Trump's expected decision to
recognize Jerusalem as Israel's capital
and order the US Embassy to move from
Tel Aviv Arab leaders warned that would
ruin the chances for peace Palestinian
leaders are calling for three days of
Rage to protest the move and Turkey's
foreign minister who met with Tillerson
this morning said the whole world is
against this Margaret Brennan is at the
White House Margaret good morning so
much to discuss here first how will this
decision disrupt if not derail the peace
initiative that is being championed by
the president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
well there really is no peace process at
this point because Jared Kushner hasn't
presented any kind of proposal but what
President Trump is doing here is
appearing to pick a side and one of
history's most intractable conflicts
Jews Muslims Christians they all
consider Jerusalem to be a holy city and
ever since Israel's seized it militarily
in 1967 all American presidents have
insisted that they negotiate with the
Palestinians to settle their dueling
claims so this is a unilateral decision
it's a major concession not clear what
the president's getting in exchange for
it and it's going to actually be pretty
popular among many of the Christian
evangelical voters who supported
President Trump so Margaret he overrules
his top advisors we hear the world
leaders are saying this is a terrible
thing that will have terrible
consequences what does president Trump
see that others don't we heard him
earlier fulfill a campaign promise
because he said it on the campaign trail
but what does he see that others do not
well fulfilling those campaign promises
is extremely important to president
Trump particularly as he comes up on
that one-year mark his first year of the
presidency he's keenly focused on
delivering on that on that message vice
president Mike Pence has been a vocal
supporter particularly of this move as I
said it's going to be very very popular
with some of the evangelical voters who
help propel President Trump
into this office it's also going to be
popular with some of the harder
right-wing pro-israel supporters many of
whom supported the Trump campaign casino
magnate Sheldon Adelson was a big
financial and political supporter of the
President and this issue in particular
was one that he highlighted highlighted
so that is what the president is keenly
keenly aware of Marvin can you talk
about the timeline of the embassy
actually moving we're gonna hear the
announcement from the president but when
will this actually be implemented
well that's key bianna because it's
watch what actually happens the US
Embassy is staying in Tel Aviv the
president's going to sign a waiver
saying that for now it stays the White
House admits it's going to take at least
three to four years to try to plan and
build a new one in Jerusalem and that
timeline pushes you past the end of the
first term of the the Trump presidency
so if President Trump stays in office
maybe it'll happen if he doesn't any
other president could change this and
Margaret quickly does it mate does it
matter that the Trump administration is
not taking a position on how Jerusalem
will be divided well that's one of the
things nor that you're right to pick up
on that listen to what the president
says today is he going to throw any kind
of bone to the the Arab countries who
are so concerned here and that could
come in the form of saying well East
Jerusalem the part of Jerusalem where
many Palestinians live that they do have
a right to that territory and to say
that in the future the United States
will also help support the creation of a
Palestinian state so if he gives those
concessions that could change the way
this is received on the streets right
now it is not clear exactly how the
president's going to present this later
this afternoon all right we'll hear what
he has to say today thank you Margaret